[Musique]
mais c'est horrible
bah je prêche porte ses sous vêtements
sales mais georges mais plein de papiers
toilettes entre moi et le tissu quoi
genre qui est pas de contacts entre ma
peau et le sous-vêtement je trouve une
fin de sa me dégoute
l'alésienne buccale je peux pas vendre
[Musique]
jean trop petit un peu mou les plus
belles chaussures trop grandes très
difficiles de marché
[Musique]
avec combien parfois mal dans les bébés
qui pleurent je mets mes écouteurs et
voilà
[Musique]
le pied quoi je préfère me connais pieds
poilus et ya de très bonnes techniques
de nos jours à l'épilation laser même la
cire ou la pince à épiler c'est un plus
petit budget doit être pour lui c'est
pas une fatalité 1
[Musique]